that balance isn't because I think there
was a movement at one point where it was
believe all women which goes completely
against our tenants of actual you know
innocent onto proven guilty it was just
if a woman says it than this and I get
it where it's come from like you said
earlier I mean you know there's been a
lot of historical wrongs against women
so there was a real natural need to you
know redress that but I think your
pendulum has just swung so full of to
the other way where it's like everyone's
suffering men are suffering but now
women actually suffering because there
are like you say a lot of your friends
are single because men are terrified